good day everyone my name is Kim Bhutto
I'm the director of computational
science and informatics from the complex
adaptive systems group at Arizona State
University I am a professor of school of
life sciences and in as well and in
today's talk I'm going to be presenting
information on how we can embrace the
complexity of cancer and how through
this embracing of the system's approach
to cancer we can get novel insights not
previously obtainable by traditional
approaches to examining the problem as
this group is more than where we're in
the middle of a tremendous
transformation in biomedicine that
transformation is embracing the concept
of personalized medicine personalized
medicine being delivering to the right
individual the right care at the right
time and in the right place this
transformation is both revolution as we
now have the capacity to look at the
very molecular nature of an individual
and their disease in particular in
cancer in tumors but this personalized
medicine transformation is also a
renaissance where we have the capacity
to not only look at the molecular
characteristics of a person but all of
the rest of the clinical and non
molecular components and integrate those
in a manner that facilitates us getting
a novel perspective on the disease and a
whole that's greater than the sum of the
individual parts this personalized
medicine revolution actually isn't
completely new and in fact as with many
things the future is already here in
many places not just evenly not yet
evenly distributed for example of this
from an article in an ad in
recent Washington Post but in fact you
can find this in almost any type of lei
presentation nowadays is an offering of
the ability to do molecular
characterizations in this instance from
our colleagues at Vanderbilt University
to help direct treatments more
specifically they've created a resource
called my cancer genome shown here on
this slide materials shown here courtesy
of our colleagues at Vanderbilt
University of my early me we're
basically one with a particular cancer
that's been molecular Lee characterized
you can see here one can select your
particular cancer type in this instance
will choose melanoma once we choose
melanoma we can see a particular type of
molecular characterization for a given
gene here showing the BRAF gene if we
see within our BRAF gene we have a
particular form of variation this type
of infrastructure now lets us decide
what type of treatment to get so I
realized well this is difficult to view
let me blow up at the bottom so with an
individual with this particular flavor
of v600e mutation one can actually see
how what the function of the mutation is
and go through this and select
particular types of agents that have
been characterized to perhaps have
differential response in individuals
with this type of disease on this
particular molecular form of cancer and
then from this then figure out what
types of interventions to take so this
is very exciting and a novel approach to
looking at cancer but I guess I want to
indicate that at best this is the tip of
the iceberg and more pragmatically
cancer itself is probably and well
established at this point to be way more
complicated than just a collection of
point mutations and that the truly
understand cancer we need to probably
look at the disease in its entire
molecular
a context so what do I mean by this well
cancer is a complex adaptive system and
I'm going to spend a little bit of time
in the next then yet walking through
what i mean by using complex adaptive
system in a molecular sense and now I'll
use it in a formal sense first we know
that cancer occurs at a somatic level at
the basic tumor level by the acquisition
of multiple mutations that ultimately
transform normal cells and a compartment
of a normal tissue into a tumor it's now
well known that these mutations actually
there are hundreds of these mutations
occurring and that these mutations don't
occur at random they actually occur in a
particular context and actually
transform the particular collection of
cells in this organ into a new organ
that there's three dimensional structure
to this and that these collections of
mutations essentially mimic this sort of
F the standard evolutionary process that
would occur in in standard and standard
speciation basically what one has is the
de novo generation of a new organ within
an organ unfortunately this new organ
isn't constrained by the traditional
multi cellular contract and has
devastating impact on one's health but
over and above this what we know is that
these alterations these hundreds of
alterations can occur not just by point
mutations for instance in individual
genes or an individual cells but in fact
there's a rich collection cancer has a
very large tool chest of alternative
ways that can actually generate these
hundreds of alterations so it can do it
via mutations it can do it by changing
the copy number amplifying big chunks of
DNA so that in fact you get the moral
equivalent of having mutated to gene by
either removing it completely and its
neighbors or by rapidly or
matically expanding its content so that
it has the so that it has the appearance
of being turned on even when in fact it
might not have had in formally
activating mutation we know that you can
actually have alterations that change
expression of genes that can actually be
the genes can still be of normal
structure and function but their
expression has been changed again either
radically increased or radically changed
at the RNA level we know that there are
non nucleic acid-based means to actually
create these alterations epigenetic
modifications that change not the
specific nucleic acid structure or the
quantity of the nucleic acid structure
but how the portfolio of changes these
are through changes of chromatin
configuration through a variety of
complex processes not only through
epigenetic processes but we can actually
change the particular portfolio by micro
RNA is the now the great deal enthusiasm
and interest in what was previously
called the junk DNA the other ninety
eight percent of the genome appears did
actually not be inner but in fact has
the capacity to have dramatic changes on
the outcome of a particular system as
well as there can be non-protein non
nucleic acid means that actually change
or can generate this portfolio of
alterations so what one sees is it's not
just simply point mutations accumulating
an individual cell there's a complex
collection of molecular processes that
can also drive the outcome we also see
that in fact these hundreds of mutations
are not occurring at random these
hundreds of mutations are targeting and
again several decades worth of biology
this described probably more than 15
years ago by Hannah Hannah and Weinberg
indicate that there's a number of
biologic processes that must be evaded
or altered if we're going to develop
cancer growth factor independence the
tumors need to evade out pack ptosis or
program cell death they need to maintain
their team
so that they don't go into senescence
they need to work to avoid cell cycle
regulation and they need to continue to
feed themselves through angiogenesis or
other processes so so we can see from
the get-go that it's more than just a
single alteration of that was such as we
saw in the earlier portion of this that
are critical you need multiple
alterations in multiple processes in
order to be able to develop a tumor well
what we also know is even as simple as
this sounds these individual processes
are actually complex networks of
interacting components so if we look at
these we can see there are multiple
sometimes dozens two networks that may
you know that are that may have as many
as a hundred different interacting
components that can all be altered in
one manner or another to generate the
specific phenotype of cancer and what we
see is that within these processes that
a given individual may have an
alteration in one set of genes whereas
another individual may have an
alteration in a different set of the
genes still targeting the same process
but no longer the same collection of
mutations or yet another person can have
another set of alterations that can
generate this process so we can see that
the underlying molecular mechanics of
the generation of tumors while it may
require hundreds of individual
components those components are non
randomly distributed through a complex
collection of networks lastly what we
know is that these germline mutations
that are these somatic mutations that
are occurring in an individual tissue
also occur in a context and then in fact
there is normal underlying variation
one's genetic constitution that can also
alter these processes so in addition to
the hundreds of somatic mutations there
are millions to tens of millions of
variants that are part of our normal
genetic constitution that vary from the
na i received from my mom versus the DNA
i received from my dad and these
variations in normal genetic
constitution can drive how one performs
angiogenesis the structure of one's
cellular matrix the specifics of one's
immune response to to both endogenous
and exogenous exposures these variants
can also have a drill dramatic effect on
how we react and respond to our
environment they can they can decrease
they can amplify they can eliminate they
can change the portfolio of response and
how a host sees chemicals viruses their
own internal hormones or ones nutrition
so we can see is that while we are at
the beginning of personalized medicine
particularly at the molecular level that
the the presumption that a single
mutation in a given gene is sufficient
to drive the full oncogenic process and
elimination or mitigation of that except
maybe a bit of an underestimate and that
in fact cancer is not only complicated
it's very complicated a number of
complex molecular interacting components
so cancer is a complex adaptive system
so what does that mean well let me walk
through a more formal definition of this
if you retain any key concept of what is
a complex adaptive system the the key
piece to remember is the whole is more
than the sum of the parts that that
simply reducing the system to its
individual parts will not capture its
complexity and that there are what we
call emergent properties that there are
features that are properties of the
system that are not simply described by
only examining its individual parts and
this is very important as we embrace
future study of cancer it
is that simply only applying the
reductionist approach of looking at
individual components may not lead us to
being able to truly understand cancer or
to do it's interventions so let me drill
down a little bit more so that's the tee
essence so a complex adaptive system
evolves over time we could see from the
molecular diagnostics that we certainly
meet that criterion cancer it has
adaptive behaviors so and as we're all
aware from those of us who familiar with
have ever been exposed individuals
treated with cancer that cancer is a
dynamic entity that changes in response
to how it is touched it displays
emergent property and that in a certain
sense not only does this complexity
suggest we may not be able to understand
cancer simply by assembling the
individual parts but it also means that
because it has emergent properties there
is the potential for unintended
consequences that it's not just simply a
plus B equals C that intervention can
have changes that we actually won't
understand until we look at it as a
system consequently to all of the above
it requires transdisciplinary study to
understand it's multi-dimensional
interactions that include the all the
fields of biology all the fields of
biomedicine and a rich ecosystem of
interacting parts I think the key thing
though they're going to focus out of
this is that cancer because of its
complex nature has interdependencies
that looking at any individual component
in isolation won't tell us the whole
story and that these interdependencies
are key in two dimensions they're key in
the dimension of of of the resources
that they require and their key in the
context of information and what I'm
going to focus on in the next section of
the talk is how do we go about studying
and evaluating these interdependencies
how do we go about understanding these
complex relationships so shown here is a
graphic that shows a standard network
and in fact it turns out that most of
natural phenomena occur and and are
engaged in network class phenomena
whether it be something is as
artificially created as the internet as
to the biologic networks that I just
described earlier in terms of driving
particular phenotypes our somatic
genetics colleagues have long now been
forced into understanding and looking at
cancer in the context of driven in the
context of network models and it's
basically because when one did the
molecular characterizations that I
described the at the beginning of the
talk the hundreds of mutations were
observed it was observed that in fact
while any given cancer may have hundreds
of mutations if we look across cancers
most of those mutations are not
recurrent they have a very low frequency
of recurrence most of them less than
five percent even the most common
recurrent mutations rarely occur at
greater than five percent we also
observe that there were variation in
gene signatures if we looked at the
transcriptome what we saw is that that
while there are the ability to see
common patterns that almost every
individual has a unique transcriptome I
think most is heartening though is that
the multi-dimensional data that was
emerging from large scale projects like
the Cancer Genome Atlas that showed
almost conflicting canceling results one
couldn't find coherence one couldn't
find a consistent pattern of outcome
that emerged as a product of looking at
these multi-dimensional cancer molecular
characterizations a similar to what I
showed at the beginning of the top so
what the somatic genetic community has
emerged is the recognition that it takes
a network and actually as we look at
these networks we can see that patterns
of coherence start to emerge
so even though for instance this is from
the early work of the Cancer Genome
Atlas Project even though we were seeing
hundreds of mutations these mutations
actually collapsed and had recurrent
patterns if we assemble them against
networks shown here are three different
networks that emerged as being important
in the development of glioblastoma
multiforme the very common form and
unfortunately still quite lethal form of
brain cancer we could see that if you
looked at alterations within these
networks that for instance the rass
signaling pathway of the raspy i 3
kinase pathway was altered in
eighty-three percent of gbms when we
looked at the p53 network or looked at
multiple members of the p53 of the p53
Network eighty-seven percent of those
were all eighty percent of individuals
with glioblastoma had an alteration in
that Network and slightly lower
frequency but still very high group of
associations as if we look at the
retinoblastoma now signaling network
again 79-78 percent of individuals had
alterations in that Network so my group
has been interested in coming up with
formal ways these have just been sort of
descriptive ways of assembling this
information we've been interested in
approaching this in a quantitative
manner and so shown in the next couple
of slides is some specific work done by
my group to identify key processes
underlying cancer by focusing on
networks but in a manner that allows us
to objectively see the alterations that
are occurring as opposed to
descriptively findings the first piece
of work I want to describe is generated
by a postdoc it that work for me saw off
Roni who's now a faculty member at bar
along bar-ilan University in Israel t he
developed a new means of examining a
computationally examining of cancer by
looking at the molecular state of
particular networks and or their
interactions
and developed a tool that allows us to
use that state information to look for
non random patterns of alterations this
pathologist tool has been now that
paradigm of this has been captured in a
new tool developed by Vaska at all that
that's actually in widespread use now
throughout the molecular community the
TCGA community called paradigm basically
the idea of this type of analysis is
that we actually look at the network is
a computable entity something that we
can say is processing information just
the same as a computer or computer
program processes information shown here
is a diagram of a network an
artificially constructed network that
has different components you can see on
the edges or the outsides of the diagram
things called ABC F and G these are
these would be genes and we can measure
the particular expression levels is
shown at the bottom of the slide
measuring whether they're present or
absent or a quantitative measure of
their level then what you see is the
black entities on this graphic the black
entities with circles are places where
the genes interact to produce or change
the state of either themselves or some
or some entity downstream so at these
interactions we can assess whether a
particular node or a particular product
is either active or consistent and let
me walk through how we do this so so we
take a network diagram such as this we
overlay the specific pattern or the
state of genes as should show not as
shown in the next slide so here we took
those individual genes overlaid their
expression pattern and blue means that
the gene is present or on red beings
that it's absent or off or up or down we
can use a variety of different ways and
what we can then do is walk through each
of the interactions let's start with
interaction one and look at jeans a
and see what we can see from the symbols
of this particular interaction is if if
a is present is and B is absent we
should get the product see the red
blockage on B would say that if B was
president it would inhibit this
interaction if a is present it should
activate or produce see so what we can
do is look at this and score and say is
this active well yes and it's consistent
because it produces see in the absence
of B let's try this again now with
interaction too we go to interaction too
and we can see in order to produce d or
to have interaction to be active we need
to have both a and B be present or they
both would need to be blue so if we
score this we can see then no 2 is not
active or two is not consistent we
shouldn't be seeing be because we need
technically a and B to be present in
order to have the product D one last
computational steps so let's look at
three where we need to have E and D
present what we need to have be present
and D absent in order to see F and in
this instance we can see that D is
present so we should not see F D should
inhibit the presence of F and in fact
that is what we see so we can score this
as inactive or or consistent so by using
these network structures we actually
change the dimension of our quantitative
or computational analysis of the network
end of the data so we're not no longer
looking at individual gene stats States
but integrating the information as
described by this biologic program and
looking for differences in patterns so
what's the impact of this well first it
helps us deal with the huge
dimensionality problem that we face in
doing biologic analysis so it reduces
the dimensionality and complexity so
rather than looking at standard gene
signature
we could see for this particular data
there would be seven signals that we
needed to be managing we can see is by
scoring pathway consistency we could go
as low as three if we look at just the
interaction so we have a more than fifty
percent reduction or complexity or if we
actually assemble this and treat the
pathway as a unit we can see that we go
all the way from seven to one so we
reduce the complexity now by seven fold
which gives us more statistical power to
look at the biologic phenomena and if we
go back and remember that much more
complicated diagram we can now look at
processes like apoptosis or look at
processes like growth factor
independence and treat them as single
entities rather than having to inherit
the noise associated with the individual
genes what we also see though is that
while they may reduce the complexity
they can also reduce some of the noise
or the differences this is now
overlaying a pattern on this particular
network that we could see if we're
scoring consistency again that if we
looked at this in the raw gene signature
space we see that there are four
differences between these two
individuals whereas if we look at
pathway state especially even at the
interactions we go from four to zero or
conceivably yeah no differences at all
in this particular data interestingly
though by looking at pathway consistency
there are instances where we amplify the
differences so we can actually measure
completely the effect of this particular
network so in gene signature space
scoring just the individual pieces of
the genes we can see that we have only
one difference between individual
between the two individuals that were
examining here whereas if we look at the
pathway consistency we can see that
there's actually three differences so
this gives us a very different approach
to examining the problem and seeing
different flavors of outcome and
different flavors of answers we've also
been interested in applying this not
just to somatic data so that as I showed
in the previous work by saw but also in
constitutional variation that millions
of variants that we inherit from our
mothers and fathers that can have
profound differences and profound impact
on our individual phenotypes this work
was done by a postdoc of mine rosemary
Braun who is now at Northwestern
University and leverage is a technique
that she developed called pathways of
distinction analysis a way to look at
constitutional variation and understand
how those patterns of constitutional
variation may differ between individuals
with alternative phenotypes what I'd
like to do is focus on some of the
outcomes of the work that a specific
example that shows why approaching the
problem from this network perspective
may be important and it leverages work
that was published by a rosemary that
leverage to publish data study by Hunter
at all that was published in Nature
Genetics in 2007 looking at a
large-scale genome wide Association
study where in the primary work they
looked at over 550,000 SNP's using an
alumina array and found a handful one or
two genes that are one or two snips that
turned out to be significantly
associated what rosemary did in this
analysis is instead of looking at the
snips individually she looked at a
almost 1,100 pathways and look to see
how the pathway is differed between
individuals with cancer and individuals
without breast cancer in this instance
just to point you to the live key and
interesting findings shown here is a
network diagram you can see how names of
we can see how names of individual law
pathways may be as misleading as names
of genes that we look up at the top here
we can see the name of this pathways
prostate cancer in fact it's a it's a
hormone regulation of pathway related to
fgf so that in particular is not
necessarily out they
into this pathway but a key finding of
the original Hunter all paper was this
gene here fgfr2 was significantly
different between individuals with
breast cancer and individuals without
breast cancer is the most significant
association is mineral repeated in a
number of individual studies what was
observed though is if you look at this
we can see that fgfr2 is actually
embedded in a very complicated network
and in Rosemary's analysis we not only
looked at in this instance fgfr2 we
shown here with the red circle but we
also looked at all of the variation in
the other genes in the pathway and what
became interesting to us as we saw that
of course here's the finding from the
original results fgfr2 highly associated
a low with a small relative odds ratio
we found that of course we could find
that that pathway was important when we
looked at the pathway including the
fgfr2 variation but what was interesting
to us is not only we saw that when we
looked at the pathway by its when we
looked at the pathway in toto we found a
slightly larger risk still very highly
significant odds ratio 1.38 with a
p-value of p2 minus 10 but what was
interesting is when we looked at this if
we dropped fgfr2 the very finding that
hunter at all had we still have a
significant association in fact an odds
ratio of 1.3 to with almost the same
significance so what we can see is it's
not just fgfr2 that's driving the
difference of what they wanted to
develops breast cancer or not but also
variation of their variation in other
genes in that network that are also
contributing to these patterns of
variation that may be causing a breast
cancer or may be important in
determining who gets breast cancer the
significance of this of course is that
it gives us alternative targets and may
also suggest to us
that it's not just a single mechanistic
approach but that in fact nature and or
cancer can leverage multiple different
variants in order to achieve the same
goal what I want to show in this is
where does the overall significance of
this particular pathway say so this is
back we're back to our shown with the
arrow here is with the fgfr2 retaining
path way we can see interestingly it is
a significant pathway in Rosemary's
analysis but over and above that it's by
far not the most significant pathway we
can see the purine metabolism calcium
signaling and other pathways are also
important in producing breast cancer and
in fact there is other ependymal logic
literature that of course would suggest
that purine metabolism and carbon and
carbon calcium signaling should and
could also be important in developing
cancer and in fact we find strong
statistically strong evidence that that
is indeed the case and find evidence for
more than just the small number of
variants that were identified in the
original study the other thing we can do
is actually create not looking at the
networks just as individual but actually
now start to assemble the effects of
networks and when we do this what we can
see is if we look at the original odds
ratio so again the hunter at all odds
ratio was around 1.3 we can see if we
actually look at the top two pathways we
now actually start to get much more
significant odds ratio so if we look at
the top two pathways from Rosemary's
analysis and note this does not even
include the fgfr2 result we can see that
we have a non sarei show instead of 1.3
we have an odds ratio of 2 point 0 2 so
2 fold excess risk rather than about a
fifty percent excess risk and we can see
if we assemble across all of these
networks we get almost a
three-and-a-half to four full excess
risk of developing breast cancer by
looking at the entire network of
susceptibility factors not just a single
SNP and it's useful to put this into
contrast of the reefs
we publish nature article where even
with looking at huge numbers of studies
and combining all of the individual
significant the individually significant
snps the maximum odds ratio that they
reach for the highest 5% risk is 2.4 and
what we can see is even with all of
these large-scale and segregating to
just the smallest number of high risk
low side we only then begin to approach
the findings that rosemary found are
looking at the individual network
components so we can see that the data
that we're approaching in cancer is
complex we can see that by doing
large-scale genomics that data is large
and I guess how do what I want to do is
start to transition into the talk from
talking about how we can mechanistically
embrace the complexity of cancer and how
we would generate and utilize this
information using our novel our
algorithmic approaches is also talked
about embracing the other complex
dimensions so this is embracing the
revolutionary piece how might we also
embrace the other components of cancer
to embrace the Renaissance speeds the
ability to integrate and utilize all of
the information in the system just the
same as our analytic approaches or
leveraging additional information in our
approach to the disease well first thing
we need to know and embrace and is that
personalized medicine is a big data
problem so what do I mean by big data i
know there's tons of tons of description
nowadays you actually can't open a
newspaper magazine or hear a TV show
even even the most recent presidential
elections in the United States a
captured or leveraged Big Data
approaches the problem so let me spend a
minute defining what is big data well
big data is both not surprising big its
large in volume and certainly in the
context of biomedicine
large scale sequence data is very big
but big data as defined in the emerging
new field is also as a large variety
which you can see we're seeing and is
problematic in on in our cancer problems
but also changes rapidly and needs to
have the capacity to do dynamic
computations so in approaching Big Data
what we realize is that it's a
multi-dimensional problem itself not
unlike any complex adaptive system well
unequivocally the genome itself is big
and we can see computationally intensive
so a given genome a sample for a given
individual the raw data the fast queue
data that comes out of a sequencer is
over 200 gigabytes of raw material and
even when processed collapses only down
to a hundred gigabytes so we get a
two-fold reduction and even if we reduce
to be honest with you to just the
essence of what differs without throwing
away a lot of the primary observational
space we're still at a hundred megabytes
per sample it's also computationally
intensive we can see that in order to
proc do the processing that I described
above we need to have hours sometimes
days of computer time and dozens of
computer processors in order to achieve
our results so again it's very large in
just processing the raw molecular data
however the genome and the molecular
data is but one dimension in our
multi-dimensional problem the genome as
said before is complemented by the
phenome we know a lot about clinical
information as well as the expose oh man
each of these individual sources of data
is at least as large as the genome or
what do I mean by this look the phenome
data is spread out and maybe a
longitudinal health record that captures
all the information across an entire
life span for an end
vigil and is quite large and is
distributed meets this very large and
distributed and complex and
heterogeneous definition of big data but
is also balu meanness in other
dimensions the Phenom data so again as
large or larger than any of the genome
data resources we can see our biomedical
imaging and increasingly the capacity to
do non-invasive characterization of
disease and disease states or specific
interventions this is actually looking
at what happens with radio label tagged
chemotherapeutic agent over time in an
individual each one of these individual
scans is as large or larger than a human
genome sequence and of course this is
but the tip of an iceberg we are seeing
unequivocally that the explosion of the
monitored self that's available through
real-time mobile devices or personal
devices that are increasingly ubiquitous
throughout the health ecosystem are
going to dwarf and require us to have
the capacity process incredibly large
volumes of data so how how should we as
biomedicine individuals and
investigation bio medicines embrace this
problem what what can we do what should
we do well I would argue following the
advice to Benjamin and in the in the
graduate student or the graduate I think
actually the future for us in
biomedicine can be simply borrowed from
a page of a very highly successful
current or activity i would say i have
one word for you all google so google
deals with big data large scale pattern
identification and analytics in real
time all day every day and what we need
to be doing in biomedicine is
approaching the problems like google now
what do i mean by this most people when
they hear google run actually quite
appropriately so think in terms of
in the search engine what I'm talking
about here though is not actually the
search capabilities per se of Google but
it's big data cap capabilities to
actually process and interpret data its
capacity to find patterns and utilize
those patterns in real time so shown
here and actually all of us are familiar
nowadays in using the google search
engine as soon as we start to type
google starts relying on the complex
underlying patterns of data of literally
tens to hundreds of millions of
individuals to understand what we may be
trying to do and look for non-random
activities that it uses then to visit
facilitate and helps it understand what
we're attempting to do we need to be
embracing similar such approaches and
analytic capabilities in our universe in
biomedicine another famous example that
probably all of us have encountered is
amazon.com or amazon so i guess if i had
a second word for you it would not be
google it would be amazon so amazon well
we're all familiar that when we actually
engage the amazon website in this
instance if i'm searching for a book
this instance too big to know about Big
Data Amazon analyzes the non random
pattern of other individuals that are
part of the activity and that have
presented and done similar sort of
surface and then uses that information
to try to identify other books or other
related activities that I might be
interested in performing and other or
other types of findings that I might be
interested in and we can use this
similar sort of approach in our approach
to in biomedicine and in analytics
across the biomedical space so this is
all part of an emerging new fourth
paradigm of science data science as it's
being leveled so forth paradigms I
science or data science
complements the traditional data
generating science with data-driven
science and in fact commonly when people
talk about fourth paradigm science or or
data science that the definition on the
second bullet here instead of saying
data generating science would say
hypothesis German science I actually I
refuse to surrender the concept of
hypothesis driven science to data
generating science and would argue that
my colleagues in astronomy physics and
economics actually are all still doing
data science and can do hypothesis based
science without actually generating or
doing de novo experiments to the best of
my knowledge we have a pretty good
confidence in planetary motion without
ever anyone physically moving a planet
today so I think that there is validity
to data science and with the appropriate
scientific construct the difference is
is whether we're generating data versus
leveraging observational data that may
already be in place so what are the
characteristics of data science well
it's data generated by instruments or
simulation we actually know from what
the previous talk we're generating tons
of data in the molecular space process
by software and the information and
knowledge is stored in computer and the
scientist analyzes using data management
statistical mathematical or algorithmic
approaches so the experiment is actually
conducted in the computer using large
data reservoirs and it's uh it's it's
ubiquitous in other fields of science
and we would actually argue is
critically important in biomedicine and
that biomedicine move into this space as
well a little attractive part I guess of
them being a data scientist is as the
harvard business review indicates it is
an up-and-coming field and i have to say
for the probably the first time ever in
my life i would be considered to be
doing sexy work by doing data science i
think maybe this falls into the universe
of geek chic that's emerging out but so
it is an up-and-coming field and so if
you're looking for career opportunities
data scientist is a
new place for you my group's been very
interested in approaching this
large-scale biomedical space through the
creation of a new data science
instrument and that science incident
we're calling a next-generation cyber
capability or NGC see so what
differentiates a data science instrument
from a traditional computational
approach is that it's well first off
we're very familiar with data generating
scientific instruments what we're
interested in doing is generating a data
science instrument that's composed of
physical capacity an elemental whole
that combines ultra high bandwidth
networks with large scale storage
measured in petabytes multiple flavors
of computation not just high performance
computing or transactional computing but
also embraces the new paradigms of big
data computing we're interested in it in
an inherently and elementally engages
logical capabilities unique software the
management of data about data or
metadata and the management of
information about data the semantics the
interrelationship of how so more than
just data about data it's how the data
is interrelated to each else lastly our
instrument that we're trying to create
at ASU is complemented by having and
again elementally composed of
transdisciplinary teams that know how to
do high performance computing know how
to use ultra high speed networks that
actually know how to generate next
generation algorithms and are not
intimidated by managing petabytes worth
of data shown on this cartoon is just
the elements Embley of that elemental
whole we can see that at the bottom of
this slide we have the computational
capacity high performance massively
parallel embarrassingly parallel jobs
that that can perform traditional high
performance computing capabilities we
also then have big data capabilities
similar to the
my performance capabilities that that
allow us to approach the problems in
this instance from a big data
perspective as opposed to traditional
high performance computing and then we
have this analytic capabilities this
logical capabilities shown at the top in
the big box here that allow us to manage
both the context of data as well as
analytic and data management resources
that we can see here on this particular
slide key to this activity though is the
rich content and what we're assembling
in our large-scale data instrument is a
diversity of types of biomedical
information from case report forms to
instrument generated data to electronic
health records the whole cornucopia of
which types of data that are and can be
accessible so our view in this is that
the key characteristic of the ng cc or
data science instrument is that it
connects all of these different types of
data and resources in a unique
environment and within that environment
allows us to step out of the hell
described by TS Eliot where nothing is
connected it allows us to leverage these
unique resources in novel ways so we
have a couple examples of how we're
already using this how the NGC C can be
served as an evidence engine by
assembling all these different types of
data and how we can actually use this in
a manner not unlike Google might use the
data or use such an infrastructure so in
this particular instance we leverage
work done while I was at the National
Cancer Institute leveraging raw data in
this instance of imaging data shown on
this slide are a bunch of imaging
characteristics and what we can do is
leveraging the ng CC class
infrastructure is look at the individual
characteristics of a single patient
think of it as your personal preferences
in ordering a book or the words that
you've typed in
to date into your Google search as it's
trying to figure out what flavor of
search you want to do then based on
these characteristics we can pull from
this large complex heterogeneous data
resource we can see what would be the
outcomes of patients that have those
particular characteristics so we can
actually choose and select patients and
use individual patients like me to see
what might be the outcome of a different
intervention or just for you as an
individual with these characteristics
how do you compare to the to the average
survival of an individual in this
instance we were looking at glioblastoma
how does your survival with your
characteristics compared to the overall
general glioblastoma survival and we can
see in this instance not radically
different which we can argue is either
positive or negative year the prognosis
is not worse but in this instance the
prognosis isn't formally better we've
also used this to explore Big Data
technology proof-of-concept by
assembling molecular sources of
molecular diverse sources of molecular
data from the Cancer Genome Atlas the
NCI nature pathway interaction database
of the NCI cancer gene index and other
information on gene drug database
information that we have available to us
to assemble across these problems so in
this type of examination what we can do
is ask simple clinical research
questions like for tumor samples which
are from patients who've had progressive
disease what are the genes that are high
amplification areas what are the genes
that have actually shown a difference in
their copy number alteration we can ask
queries such as retrieve the gene
expression scores for all the genes that
share a high amplification region and
find out how that changed chemotherapy
response does it alter chemotherapy
response or lastly we can look at genes
that have a documented association with
one or more drug
and see if they are in known
amplification region so so we've
actually done these tests flurries in a
proof of concept of this particular type
of work but what's exciting to us is not
this particular clinical research
questions but actually the potential Big
Data questions that would feed not just
clinical research but overall clinical
outcome like given clinical demographic
and lifestyle characters is
characteristics of this patient how to
survival different differ among
alternative interventions are they're
all what are the adverse events
associated with particular alternative
treatments are their quality of life
differences associated with these
alternatives and more pragmatically and
perhaps full circle in our conversation
of Renaissance what might be the right
intervention for me given both high
molecular as well as other clinical
characteristics so in summary we're
approaching in our group cancer is a
complex adaptive system and we think
that it helps us address some of the
challenges that the cancer community is
currently facing in both understanding
disease and hopefully directing new
development of challenge of new
development of therapeutics and
interventions we believe it's
technically feasible to create and
deploy technology to exchange
information within and between members
of this complex ecosystem and we believe
that new network models will help us
augment the sort of genome organization
models to manipulating and understanding
data and lastly that if we're going to
approach cancer as a network we're going
to need a multi-stakeholder
multi-dimensional community to address
these problems so with that I'm very
interested and happy to take questions
please feel free to enter your questions
into the question block I will actually
go through those questions reading them
from
members of the community and then
attempting to answer them so please feel
free at this time to enter questions
into the Q&A session of this and before
before I close and go into questions
we're very very interested in having
collaborators in this project so I
encourage any of you who all might be
interested in this to drop me a note
that Kenneth buetow at asu.edu and we'd
welcome the chance to collaborate and
continue this conversation so what we'll
do is open the questions here and see if
we actually have any incoming questions
at this point again I'd ask you all to
please enter your questions in the
question and answer box looking forward
to the opportunity to more directly
engage with you also if you have any
specific questions I welcome the chance
to address those questions I can see
that someone someone has indicated
they're having a little bit of trouble
using the question box it's saying that
if they can enter questions but they
can't save them I think that look
through it encourage you to try try yet
again if there are if perhaps if you
have specific questions I would welcome
the chance to see if there's a that I
could answer anything that folks have I
think that this is an interesting and
exciting area that permits us to
conceivably look at and address
particular questions we're happy to
share out I believe that one of the
questions that's a raised is a can the
powerpoints be shared i believe they're
available love the whole webcast will be
available and we're happy if if you drop
me a note i'm actually happy to send
them to you all and
or would be happy to do what I might do
to be able to share the limit area we
threw so actually I'm happy to share and
I I can see the question related about
saving had to do with or entering I had
to do with actually slide so are there
any questions that I can ask her or that
the community has I could answer related
to the particular talk so i can see then
i have a question here relating to you
start with the first question so it says
let me look at the full question if i
look at this question it says that the
question says we go back sorry how many
questions if i look at the questions
that are before me see so it says you
think researchers could be planning
projects where they could collect
experimental data and compare it using
these tools and the short answer to this
question is is absolutely and I think
part of what we're attempting to do is
create an open source infrastructure
that would permit one to approach these
problems on a large scale and we would
look forward to working with anybody
both ensuring out the specific tooling
that we've created as well as a bringing
in specific data okay I have a question
related to the is it possible to
understand calcium signaling and cancer
so as I pointed out in the breast cancer
analysis in fact the calcium signature
allows us to integrate what's been
described on an individual locust I
locusts but basis uh and and then she
and then what we can do is dissect based
on
that this particular signaling pathway
is important find which of the
individual components and or which are
the individual variants and how they
combine to produce this particular
outcome are there other questions so
I'll give folks a minute or two more we
have another minute or so before we're
formally over what I would like to
suggest a just in closing is that if
there are no additional questions that I
point you all to the obtaining CME
credits or continuing medical education
or get continuing education credits or
continuing medical education credits go
to the address shown on the slide here
ww bio conference live com and you can
actually take the test and go through
and get a fish ille credit for
participating in this lecture and
hearing the results again I'd like to
thank you all for your time by my e I'm
welcome individual contacts if folks
want to touch me directly up it's
possible to download these slides by
going in the contents button of your
screen and to be able to capture the
information and as well as the I know
the webcast will be made available
shortly so thank you all for your time
uh please feel free to go to the
continuing education credit locale and
with that I say thank you
you